Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
Brasil es el único país de América
Latina que con sede visados humanitarios
a los refugiados de Afganistán hasta la
fecha fueron emitidas más de 6.000 visas
desde enero de 2022 entraron al país
unos 4.500 afganos por el Aeropuerto
Internacional de Sao Paulo sin embargo
la falta de infraestructura y de un
presupuesto específico para la acogida
hacen que decenas de asilados tengan que
quedarse durante semanas en el
aeropuerto hasta encontrar un hogar
nuestra corresponsal en Brasil Valeria
sacone estuvo con algunos de ellos
las horas transcurren lentamente para
decenas de refugiados afganos que están
a la espera de una plaza en una casa de
acogida
paraguasic la hora del té es Sagrada
Este joven periodista pertenece a la
etnia hazara perseguida por los
talibanes
vinimos aquí en busca de una situación
mejor con la esperanza de encontrar una
sociedad sin discriminación para poder
continuar con nuestros estudios tener
derecho a trabajar a una vida mejor
tuvo que huir dejando atrás a su familia
enba Millán la ciudad donde los
talibanes destruyeron las estatuas de
los budas gigantes Ahora tiene que
lidiar con otra situación precaria en un
país desconocido
no tenemos baño ni cocina los niños no
ven La luz del sol
es una situación dura pero todos los
días nos traen comida
Brasil es el único país de América
Latina que concede visados humanitarios
a los afganos pero el gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro no otorgó fondos para la
manutención de esos refugiados todo el
peso recae sobre la ciudad de guaruleos
donde se encuentra el Aeropuerto
Internacional
en agosto en agosto el número de
refugiados creció absurdamente Así que
pasamos de 4 a 5 personas al mes a 200
entonces la acción humanitaria precisa
ser más fuerte nosotros garantizamos la
seguridad alimentaria de estas personas
a través del desayuno del almuerzo y la
cena
esta portavoz de acnur la agencia de la
ONU para los refugiados explica que la
inmigración afgana en Brasil es un
fenómeno novedoso
cerca del 50% de los refugiados tiene
estudios superiores entonces son las
personas que tienen más ingresos porque
llegar hasta Brasil comprar el tiquete
es bastante caro Y eso también amplifica
sus expectativas hay periodistas
políticos médicos enfermeros incluso
colegas nuestros de Naciones Unidas en
la actualidad hay más de tres millones y
medio de refugiados afganos en el mundo
acnur Espera que el ejemplo de Brasil
puede hacer replicado en otros países
latinoamericanos
casas de acogida administradas por
organizaciones humanitarias reciben a
los refugiados afganos que duermen en el
Aeropuerto Internacional de Sao Paulo
luego de su llegada al país pero algunas
familias rechazan esta solución los que
aceptan comienzan una vida junto a
personas de otras etnias que en
Afganistán estaban en conflicto es una
situación desafiante para los
voluntarios de ongs esta es la historia
Este joven de 29 años llegó solo a
Brasil su familia tuvo que quedarse en
Irán a la espera de un visado
bienvenido
Gracias desde el inicio de diciembre
Apple fácil vive en este cuarto que
comparte con otros compatriotas
somos seis personas hay una cama para
cada uno y esta es mi cama
su prioridad es aprender portugués
cuanto antes para poder reanudar sus
estudios su sueño es ser ingeniero
a lo mejor voy a trabajar mientras
termine la universidad
en el futuro quiero que venga mi familia
y que podamos vivir en un sitio mejor
como Brasil
sonrisa
la llegada de los afganos supone un reto
para las organizaciones humanitarias que
lidian con ellos En primera línea
cada movimiento migratorio tiene una
especificidad Y esta es una cultura muy
específica no tienen un solo idioma
hablan más de una lengua muchos son
dialectos hay dificultad para
comunicarse para comer para hablar con
las mujeres porque es el hombre El que
habla el que toma las decisiones además
han llegado tres etnias que tienen un
conflicto histórico y que terminan
quedándose el mismo espacio en el mismo
lugar son todos desafíos
otra dificultad es mantener sus
costumbres Como por ejemplo encontrar
carne halal cortada según el Rito
musulmán
las mujeres afganas prefieren cocinar su
propia comida para matar la nostalgia De
su tierra Porque todos ellos se vieron
obligados a marcharse algún día Les
gustaría volver pero solo a un país en
paz
Aunque miles de kilómetros y un idioma
los separen de lo conocido Brasil
continúa como un inesperado destino para
los afganos que huyen del talibán con
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva la cabeza del
gobierno queda pendiente el tema para la
gestión de la acogida hasta que
inmigrantes de France 24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrante f24 sigan con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]